Thank you for being in this
law initiative with Mexico, it is a
super event and here we are going to give you
all my name, Charles,
web accessibility, improving the Internet with a few lines
of code.
social and in the
bottom part of the screen
the accessibility icon is appearing
okay then who am I my
name is david flores de flores is
my personal brand
I am accessibility advocate I work
globally I like things from google cloud I
like  very much the web
I belong to a program called
platz and master that also I do not know if you have
heard of it but it is a
high performance program where
we train for a certain time to
achieve our
professional objectives I do not like fair
best fight fire very much  beige rectangular excuse me
and this and well I also belong to the
dgdc cloud mx community so we
're going to fight a little bit, it's
the same if you have questions, doubts or
anything else you want us to
answer,
write it in the chat and with all pleasure
it's okay
wait a  a little bit because we stopped
listening to you for a little bit no in fact that's the
experiment so the slide has the one
about how you felt
so I would like them to put
how they felt there in the chat because
exactly what I just went through is the
reality of many people who
For example, they have a hearing disability, no, there
are talks and conferences, there is a lot of
content, but no subtitles, so I
wanted to share this
experiment with you and I would like to know
how you felt about it, no,
because a lot of accessibility means
putting ourselves in the shoes of people
who  They have a disability and so we can
understand what they go through on a day-to-
day basis. No, then go back to the slide a little bit
and well, this is the order of the
day.
with a year for this to see how we are
located around the world with
this topic the most common errors how we
can solve them and some tips and
tools that also help us to
make our websites more
accessible and an example with code
because I think yes  We stay in electric, it
's not so long, so we have to
put it into practice, okay, let's
rule out the most obvious question because
it is called 11 and 11 d in Spanish and it is
because the
first word of accessibility is in the first one, it is
because there are 11  characters between a and
ye and curiously also in Spanish not
that this accessibility is 11 characters
between an and d
so once we clarify this let's go
to the hard data not that it is a
disability well this is a
general term that covers
deficiencies  the limitations of the
activity and the restrictions on the
participation of people in certain
daily activities, such as going to the
supermarket to the hat, it can be going to the
bank or even I don't know how to answer a
phone and well,
different types of disabilities arise from there, the
truth is  that at some point in
our lives we all suffer from some type of
disability, whether temporary or
permanent, which is temporary, temporary,
for example, or situational, it can also be read, it is
called, let's imagine that we are
carrying our puppy or a baby or
a bag and  with one hand we have to
use the telephone because we have one hand
busy so that is a
situational disability because at the moment we
cannot use our two hands
temporary it could be, for example, that we
suffered an injury we broke a
bone and for the moment we already have  It is
a part of the body in a cast and that is why
we cannot make use of that extremity
for the moment and permanently, since it is
when we have to use a wheelchair,
crutches, canes or some other
device that helps us carry
out our day-to-day activities.
way between quotes normal no and
good here comes a very hard fact
that they say that very good they do not say the
world health organization
does a study and says that 15% of the
population suffers from some type of
disability and this means that they are
more  of a billion people those who
live with a disability in their day to
day thanks to technological advances
people who have some type of
disability because their life span is
longer and this is super cool
because we can enjoy more things the
problem  It is when I don't know in their day to day there
are many barriers to the
activities they have to do, such as
going to the supermarket, going to the bank or
even going to a building. How many
times have we not seen these
buildings that are not suitable
for people who  they need a ramp they
need a special elevator and
well, things start to get complicated
then, well, the
internet consortium the w3c
agreed and said ok
this is a big problem that is
affecting people a lot
we have to do  something to be able to
solve it and that's when they start
to do a lot of research and they say ok
so let's make our mouths that it is also
the web content accessibility guidelines
where they compiled all this information
and they said ok this information is going to be
general it will be used to create furniture
to create  Buildings to create the web in
general will be used for a large
number of things
from here on they said ah ok if it is
with the one we have this research
but there is class we have to classify it a
little more so that it can be understandable and
can be usable by the  So, the largest number
of people divided it into these
four large bullets that we see here
that are perceptible, operable, understandable,
and robust, perceptible, as the word
says, is that we can capture everything we
see on the screen, that it is not difficult for us,
well, to be able to differentiate
between a  button a link or things
like that the other is that it be operable this
means that if we click on a
button it should work that if we open
a translator it should also work
the other is that it is understandable that
we do not have so many elements on the
screen  and well right now focused on the web
that we don't see so many elements on the
screen so that we can capture and
understand all the information that is
happening in front of us and the
last point is that it is robust, this
means that it is compatible with the
greatest amount of technology to  systems
that exist so far that is
assistive technology can be
braille keyboards where they appear as certain
dots so that people who cannot
see can read what is happening on
the screen it can be
screen readers or screen riders where they announce
everything that is  happening on the screen
or it can be special magnifying glasses that make
the content of the web bigger and
also from here there are three levels
being the lowest level and triple the
highest so each of these
versions of the uca has different
this the  mouth chipset there are
different versions 2.0 22 21 and
2.2 that are being released this year
what is the big difference because as
we can see the release dates of
each of these versions
has more to do with the devices
that exist in  each of the times,
for example, in 2008 there were not so many
mobile devices and they
were not used much for daily use,
however, in 2010 and 8, which is
version 2.1, now
all mobile devices are taken into account
to make  a more accessible website and
well, like that of 2021, well, there are, for
example, smart watches or just
everyday tasks like we see the
clock and we can see it now as
a person who cannot see would do,
for example, then they always start
to take  take into account the new
devices or the new
usability patterns that are existing ok
ok now we are going to enter the state of
accessibility of accessibility sorry
this organization the web
m which is web accessibility in mind every
year it begins to be an analysis scan it
begins to interview people  that make
the web and begin to collect this data
to present us with this information that we
see here last year analyzed more than
a million pages and well we could
realize that at least 98
percent of the pages have an error
related to the  version 2.0 of the
guide that we saw previously,
then it is also considered that
version 2.0 is the minimum achievable to
comply with accessibility, so yes, at
least we have a saying of that level, an
accessibility error of that level, because
it will be difficult to make a web more
accessible to people, it was also
found that the average number of
errors found per page
is 60, so there are many for
when we want to transmit the
information to a person who has
some type of disability
and continuing with this state, here are
the six as errors  larger than were
found on pages where 86%
of all pages had problems
with color contrast what does
this mean that maybe there were letters that their
color was not as prominent against the background
why should there be a rule with
which this minimum contrast must be met
and it is impossible to see it because
well, there are people who
see and do not see if there are people who
suffer from high blood sugar who are
diabetics and see spots on the screen
or people who cannot  see the
combination with red or blue and well
there is a large amount of variation of
visual disabilities and 86% of
these pages do not go beyond that if
this activity is accepted to comply with
accessibility the other most common is that and
well I would also like  that here
you told me in the chat how many
of you use images on the web and do not
put an alternative text or
simply forget to put the
altex attribute and so they send to
display no 66 percent of the
pages had this error the  Another is
that there are also empty links, for example, they
have cut the html tag that
goes without a link, so it is also a
big mistake and there are also inputs that do not
have a bold law, the balls are
important because people who
use a screen ryder  When
going through those inputs, they want to get
tangled up, they say ok, look at this input
from email, it's from your email, it's from your
password, for example, and if they don't have
these labels, let's do the test
ourselves, what would happen if we use a screen
reader and don't  it tells us what the
component is for, no
empty buttons, how many of us
have also used buttons where we
only put the icon, for
example the one with the trash can, which we
can visually say, oh, it's a
trash can, but if it doesn't have a label, if it does
n't  a text the king screen of
balsera ok this is a button but they didn't
define the text I can't
tell you what it is for and well that's how
a total decompression of the
page is generated and finally this is the language
that is not specified in the  taj to html
the famous link attribute where we
define the main language of our
page as well as
assistive technologies can take the
machine language by default and in this way
it knows how to pronounce all the
content that we are seeing on the web
but for example  If we enter a website
that is in Spanish and our
main language of the machine on which
we are using the website is English, the
pronunciation will not be correct,
so that is the other big
site.
Now we are going to see the most
common errors.  I have also noticed
how we make mistakes when
we design or develop the web and some
brief explanations of how we
can solve it at the end of all this,
well, let's go to an example to see
how we can apply it, okay,
well, what I said
first  It is the language, many of us would think
that only the language would go in the part
here of the html to specify the
main language, which is the minimum
expected, but suppose we have
diverse content, no, then this
lanka attribute
can also be used in some other places
where we combine  I don't know Spanish with
English as is the case and we
can specify they read each of the
labels the language and then he
writes them ryder they say ah ok automatically I
have to listen to the
Spanish accent to be able to pronounce it
correctly and then that's it  We don't
create so many language barriers with
people who can't
see the page, okay, and continuing with
this, there's a very interesting button that
I'd like to know if they
got to see it on github when we
started browsing with it.  keyboard the
first tap we do within the
page is this little blue button that says
your content. I don't know if anyone has
seen it in hip hop,
well, leave it in the comments
and this button is precisely to
make it easier for the user to navigate
through all the  page what do I mean
by this for example in hip hop we see that it
has a search engine it has a
large menu that says by request well
with each of these options later
notifications more options my profile and
then I can navigate to the
main content but what  What if I already know
all this part of the
github hits page and I want to skip to the
main content, then this is
where this script or content button comes into action
where if what we
create automatically we jump to the
main content and  We skip all
that part of the header to navigate from
option to option until we reach the
main content. This is very
important because we make it easy
for users to move
faster between all the content on
our page without getting lost in each
one.  of the elements is worth
this
other very common network is that we
create elements we create links that
open external links but most
of the time we open them within the
page in which we are positioned
that is a great accessibility error
because imagine that I cannot  use
the mouse and only use the keyboard in
what it will take me to return to that
page and to that specific section I don't know
or it was a search and it took me
a long time to find it so that suddenly
when I find a link it takes me out of that
page  And well, I already lost all that
information or the search I was
doing, so it's very difficult
to do it that way, that's why
all external links always have
this little button, this unknown, sorry, you
see here that it's like a little window with
an arrow pointing out, so
visually we can identify and
say oh ok
this link will open a new window for me
so accessibility not
only helps people with
disabilities but also helps us to
identify certain certain processes or
certain activities or behaviors
that the elements are going to have then well
that  It is of great help in that
here something very interesting happens that in a
visual way we are
transmitting what I told you not about what it
says with external link this part
that is here enclosed in the little
red square and the landmark icon that tells us that they are going to
open a  in a new window but
now how do we do it with users who
can't see because there are some very
interesting hacks on how we can give you
information on specifying the screen
riders so that they transmit this
information to them so on the screen
below there is a little box
red where it says the link with external
link open and granddaughter open the new tab is a
hidden spam inside this link
that can be reached by the screen
ryder but we can't see it with the naked eye
so if you realize this
way we are transmitting  in the same
information to people and to people who
cannot see and we make life
a little easier for them, okay then
these tricks are super
interesting
the other is the navigation order the
navigation order to navigate with
keyboards or assistive technologies is
up down left to right what
does this mean that we are always going to
follow that chronological order so that
we can understand what is
happening on the web going a little
more on the technical side is to order our
html tags in doom so that they
can be found that way  the tab
for example and the user can
go through them without problems here in this case
I ran a google chrome tool
called tabal and just in a little while he
presented them where we run it and
automatically it starts to put the steps
of what would be the  navigation order of
this page
so here on this adobe page
we can see that if the order of is
correct I think it is not easy to see
very well but well it is marking us
with 0 with 1 with 2 and so on one of
the  elements in order from top to bottom
left to right, so
this allows navigation to be much
faster and we begin to give the user
context of what is happening on
the page. It is like us, there
are studies where people who do not
have visual disabilities  They tell them ok
this part we are going to put this page we are going
to put some special glasses that
begin to read the movement of the
retina and from there we are going to see how we can
present the content better
then because of these studies they say
that in this way our  eyes
go through all the information first
we go through the menu then the
main content which in this case is the spin
that says cyber monday with 40
percent etc. and so on with all the
elements until we reach the last one ok I
don't know if we have more questions up to here
here I see a question that says the language
in the tags was only for when they
are different from the one in the html without
exactly, I go back quickly
for example in this case if all the
language were in Spanish it would not be
necessary to specify these because
well already  It would be all the content and the
same pronunciation if we mixed
some things in English if it would be
necessary to specify it in the
sections where we have English in this
aspect or for example there are some
pages that make this switch from Spanish
to English it is important to modify this
this attribute here  So that it can be
read in a better way by
assistive technologies,
then continuing we start with now
a little more problems with
suppose that we already know all of the
above and we say ok we are going to layout and
suddenly from design we get these
types of buttons like the  rhythm or read
more or click here or promotion
here so at the end of the day
we remember that when users
use a keyboard to navigate they have
two options that we will
see later is to navigate with the
up and down arrows  to go through absolutely
all the elements or navigate with the
is key with the tab key we begin to
navigate through each of the
interactive elements which is an
interactive element they are buttons they are links they are
inputs they are forms they are all these
elements that have some action
so let's suppose  that we are
browsing a
complete blog and suddenly 15
buttons appear that say rhythm or read more
so yes, that is, even we
listen to them because it does not give us much
context, we will not know what
they are for, what action they are going to
trigger or  if you're going to throw me around
then it's hard to understand
so that's why the texts have to be
given context for
people who use
assistive technologies and some other techniques is to
combine, for example, the title of in the
section in which it is  the button to read
more and combine it with the text of the button
so it says read more followed by the
title not read more news about
sports so it already gives a little more
context okay
in the part here they make up the
next part is to tell the user the
states or  the status of the components
because there are elements that are displayed, there are
elements that are collapsed, there are
elements that open a menu and
an infinity of elements if we start to
analyze to remember everything we do,
there are elements that carry out certain
activities,
well, there in the team  I know
the example of a drop down if someone
also has there is an example that
they are remembering would be a link to
put it in the chat
ok so
there are attributes that we can
use to define this part for
example with area that is this this
technology  where if suddenly the html
is not enough for us we
use it to cover that gap between the
behavior and the html that we have
then with some daily properties
we can say ok when it
has expanded you are going to set it true and
automatically the screen  reader will
understand it and will say ah ok
with this attribute I am going to tell you
when it is collapsed or when it is the
other way around as in the example of the
image in the red part here in the little
red square we see that it tells us
collapsed  No, then this means that
this element is collapsed and
closed. This helps us to give
the user a good context when an
element is interactive or not. Here are
some very interesting topics about
how far we can go with html, for
example, because they exist, it takes a lot
that we can use to make a good
html but there are certain elements that are
also called plugins the w3c
calls them plugins where we have to
combine behavior with area and
some others in some other tags
sorry in order to obtain the
desired behavior as for example
it is  a drop down or that many times is
a button and is a section with a list
of options and combined they already make us what
this is the drop is and with the
correct attributes we can
indicate to the user the state of that
component collapsed collapsed closed or
deleted or selected and among some
others they go
and here comes something very interesting and I
would like to know in the chat how many of
you have worried about the order
of the headings in your web pages I
still give 15 seconds well what it
took
[Music]
ok  the order of the hennings is of the utmost
importance
because assistive technologies not
only read us the content that is
on the page but also provide us with
very interesting tools for
us to navigate between all the content
just like when we read
a book and want to go to a section
Specifically, what do we do? Well, we go to the
index to see where
assistive technologies can also jump. In
this case, I'm going to concentrate a lot on
envy, which is a leading script for
Windows and well, it's free. The next one
is Josh, but it's paid.  so for
example envy and it provides us with a
special menu in which we
can navigate we can introduce us and
tell us ok this page has these
sections it has these buttons it has
these links and it has all these headings
in chronological order in which you
can jump to see  all the
information
then that is why the importance of
the hennings on the page so that
we provide them even more
easily
with disabilities that they can jump between
all the content
apart from this there is a very
important rule that says that at least one
page must  to have an h 1 and there
should only be one h 1 on the entire
page there can be several h 2 several
h 3 but it is also very good practice
to put or use them in
descending order to continue having an order
what do I mean by this for example  In
the first image we see that there is an h 1
that says main title and then there is
a container that has an h 2 and an h 3
in that order so that is what is expected
because there is an h 3 and before there is an h 2
and before there is  an h 1 then in that
order if they can be used without
instead in the second image where it says
incorrect if we have an h 1 then we
have the same container then
we have an h 4 and an h 6 this is a bad
practice because if we are presented with the same
The menu that assistive technology told you about
may get confused and you
can take it as an
independent section, you cannot index it or you
may simply omit this part and
not tell the user that they can
get there quickly, so
since there is no h  5 there is not even an h 3
and an h 2 we cannot use an h 4
good if we can lend the practice and
well this at the end of the day makes it
more difficult to use a web page
the same if I spend time or it already takes
an hour  They warn us to close
this one super fast and well, we come to the
interesting part about the tools
that we can use, for example, in the
first image below the title we can
see a Braille keyboard that has some
buttons for people who cannot see
and navigate between all the content  And that
content doesn't start, well, they
start to be presented to people who can't
see in this little bar here where
you can see a lot of dots, so they start
to move super fast and people
start to see the screen with their fingers,
so it's super incredible,
but  well, leaving the web a little bit, there
is also this world in
video games where, for example, xbox has
this super control that we see here in the
center that has two large elements and
has a lot of connections to
connect peripherals so we can
connect pedals, buttons, I don't know if there are
a person who only has a
part of their arms or their limbs
can use these big buttons to
hit the controller and well, keep
playing then we see that this
is evolving more and more for the same reason that
people with disabilities
are living more and more  and it's not fair that
they live with so many limitations so we
're getting closer and closer to
making life more accessible and a
little easier for people with
disabilities
so what are the tools
this is a very cool one it's called accept
tools which is a  plugin in which
we can install in the
browser and automatically it does not
begin to detect all the sites that
have our page, it even tells us
the criticality of security, sorry if it is
moderate or minor serious critical
and good, it helps us to do a
super analysis  A quick scan on our
page to see this
accessibility status in a little while we can also see
how the aiei es camps site is
to see if someone with a disability
found any difficulty here,
what is the problem of this one who
only finds
structural problems or  semantic and this
only means a maximum of 30 to 55
percent of errors that we can
find in the pages because
the tools are not magical and from
here we would need to jump to a
manual test to verify and cover all
the other large percentage that  No
tools are reported
and it has a free version, it has a
paid version, obviously, the
paid version is very expensive, because
some other things are needed, such as
artificial intelligence,
image detection of texts, and well, it is a
very complete tool and I think it is
the most  safe so far I don't know if
anyone of you has known neuchatel,
well, this tool is
developed by a company
called liquid, it is written as usa,
which is pronounced dike and is
100% focused on accessibility, so if
anyone wants to get involved  fully into this
world with them you can learn
a lot, they even have a very
interesting school to learn about
accessibility, certify tea and other
things,
other tools such as
screen riders, for example, here is
envy and josh and voiceover, which are like
the most used  In the market this
year I began to gain a lot of
market because Nvidia always begins to
make improvements and its use began to drop a
little because it
is only available for Windows and it is not as
powerful as what they
provide us with many methods in
navigation, as I had already told you,
they announce all the changes that
the components can have on the
page and, well, with each one of
them we can find
navigation methods to find the content
super fast, the same in the example in the
exercise, we are going to see envy and  how
this works the tools to
verify the color contrast are
of the utmost importance because we
believed that only if it stands out from the
background and with that we could not put it
but there are some other diseases such as
what we are seeing
in the image of  here where it helps us to
emulate different types of
visual impairment and this is because they are tools
implemented in the browser or there are
some others such as at the end
of the meeting of this workshop
I share these links of the
presentation so that you can access  to
them and they can take a look but let's see let's
see these links here for
example
this is a tool developed
by this company called dick
and where if we put a color
automatically it will tell us
the ratio and if we are passing some of
the accessibility pitfalls that
we mentioned at the beginning, such as
what is double a and triple a no, so
for example if we use this
color contrast, well, we don't pass, then
we can start playing here
with the colors or with the ones that
weeks or will present to us  visual design to
implement on our page and we
can immediately see how we pass or not
pass this
color contrast another
cool tool that is here is the one from adobe
in adobe and when we enter
our color palettes there is also
an option where we  we can see the
accessibility found here that
says accessibility tool and it tells us oh
ok what level of accessibility you want and
we can check it here and
well start playing with the colors or
with the proposed colors to see this
if we pass we pass
but david there is no easier way
to check if there is this other
tool
that develops it from old age and that is an
application that we can install
on our computer and it gives us a little
window like this where we
can take the color from anywhere and be able to
analyze for example in this
case the for ground and aguán where once
we go to the laws page to see
this as it is in terms of
contrasting color and suppose this part of
aquino that says November 29, 30 and
December 1  of 2021 online so let
's analyze, for example, the color but
let's analyze the color of the letter and
analyze the color of the background
so we can see that in this case
the color contrast is happening and
well here it even tells us the
ratio tells us for the version  out of the
mouth what we are going through and well it is
super cool and unfortunately this
is only available for windows and
for mac and for linux since it causes
tools like the first two that I
had presented to you
well that one on the side of the most
common errors so what about this next
Well, we put all this into practice
to see how we can start. I don't know
if there are more questions in the chat, how
long did I stay? Sorry
[Music]
I think it's all to blame. Well, let's
go to the code to see what we can
do.
I have this example of it's a  page
built super fast nothing complicated we
have a header we have this a title
text buttons images this
informative elements different sections and this
and an outside for example
then well at
first glance well no
big problem all the link and this and
well apparently it is  a
simple page but well done but it is where we are going
to start using our
first tool which was the one that I
told you is called aqs depp tools which is
a plugin for the browser that we
can run on the webs for
example let's do the exercise  about the
law the law is com and let's see what
problems are found on this
page well we can see that there are 66
sites of which 20 are critical 29
are serious moderate they are 12 and minors well
there 0
so how do we use it with all its
power this tool ok in the part
here we can find all
these sites I don't know if it can be seen
well or I give it more man
[Music]
and
well I don't see anything here in the chat
so it continued the same as any
case well here I am waiting  to the
chat and this and well here we can see
all the sites that mark us for
example that the elements do not have
a contrast enough to make it
clear of which there are 34 and this and
so with each of them
that is  This section here also
has very interesting options, such
as if we select
each of these floors at the
bottom, the options begin to change,
here we have four very
interesting options, the first one is called
highlight to be able to highlight where
that  said of the 34
so look I'm going to click on it and
this part here was highlighted because it
tells me ok this part there does not meet
the minimum color to be able to see it without
any problem so here there
are also little arrows where we can see the 34
of those  sites related to color
so if I click next it will jump
to the next element and it tells me the
same thing there, not that it does not have enough color,
for example let's go to this one that says that
this element does not have alternative text and that is why it
marks it as said  now going in the
part below we have this
little button that says in spain where
we can see directly in the
dom where that start is marked and
used that there is look it is here and if
precisely because we have he is here
img we have the short of the  image
we have classes we have something that is a
data it seems that they are haitian and we
have lost the alt ex so
let's remember that all the images that
we use on the web must
have an alternative text
now what happens if the image is only
decorative it does not transmit information no
they transmit nothing to perform any
operation on the page because it is still
necessary to use the attribute to lt but
with quotes that open and close so
that you can
at least that way screen
ryder finds it and says here is an
empty alternative text is  A
decorative image is fine, it's like one
of the examples we have here, well,
here we have an image,
it's good, here's a start because it
doesn't have the alt ex either, but when we
're going to see it later, where the
expansion als mean images
decorations and going back to the
tool and we have this option that
says more info where, well, if we
click on it, it takes us to the documentation
where they explain each
of these sites in more depth and how you can see, well,
it tells us, ok, are you  breaking
rule
1.1.1 of the mouth
and this is how you can
solve it and well there we see the
documentation now something very
interesting this is the quick reference
of the mouth why good if we
go to the mouth
and open it  In this case, version 2.1
is good, it's an accessibility company,
it's this part here, the information is
immense, it's very general, and maybe to
a certain degree we start to lose ourselves in
everything in all this information because,
well, it's not understood at the end of the day.  It's
general
[Music]
So, what can we do to
understand each of these sites a little better
? Well, there is a quick
reference where now, if all this is
more oriented towards development,
for example, we saw each other a while ago, which is
111 in Watford.  With this, what's up, well,
we come here and say
ok, so it has to do with the
content of the text, no, so if
we want more information here we can
read it a little more, if we want even more
information, we can display this button
and it explains technical problems.
examples where they use it where they don't use it
and a lot of information where we
can spend even a week to
understand why this edition existed and
the cool thing about all this is that it also
tells us the level of accessibility in this
case well it is
but what happens  If my approach is more to
2.0 and here I am looking at 2.1 rules,
well, very simple, in the part here
where the content is, there is a tap that
says filter where we can
say of all these versions which one I
will want, for example, 2.0  and good
level of accessibility, which one am I going to want?
No, I'm only going to want double
a and triple a there, it's out of our
out of the current broom.
that
fall within our scope, for
example, in this case, they already
appear in gray because they are not within
our scope and they are only
showing us what we request in the
filter, so this is also a
good help to continue with
accessibility and  I saw that the album was moved here
ok here I have a question and it says you
can have several h1 in an
html 5 page it says that with the section you can
restart
the consecutive of the hennings if you can
use it with the sections but also
remember that the sections need a
title so that it can be identified
by assistive technologies even
something very strange is that each
new window that opens on the screen is
well each element that opens on
the screen is considered as a new
window and there we can also use
achón or the example  The most common is a modal
that if we open a modal this
window expands and there we can also use
h1 but always if we use h1 within
an email for example it is only
recommended that one be used and here it
says what happens with the hierarchy of those
of  The sessions and the tips are there any
recommendations if I'll give it the
right one, I don't know where they're seeing us from,
but in Mexico we use the tortilla
for everyone, not to put
anything in it, so there is a joke that a
dip is not like a tortilla, no.  we can
put so many things there are many things
inside a dip why are there
specific taxis
the hierarchy the truth is that they do not have a
hierarchy as such it all depends on how
you order them or how you
declare them in your code so that they are
reflected in the  dom then until
they are in the dom is where you see what
hierarchy one is going to have and what hierarchy
another is going to have then that is how
I think the most complete answer to this
question
well then going back to this of
the rules well we already understood  how
to look for the rules we already understood how to
solve it, we also found
very excellent documentation to be
able to solve it and well, that way
we can solve each of the
problems that appear here and now,
more relevant information, for example, the
impact when the type of test that was found was found
He made it automatic and
very interesting tacs, such as
cut from the category alternative text
of the version of the mouth that you are
breaking.
section 508 that this is a
law that the usa has on accessibility
is worth and well something some extra information
the same about lithium and now what happens if
we are clueless if we did not go to the
documentation well in the part here it
also tells us oh ok look  in this
part here is where the
error is
this is the code of the lumen where
you can find it and here are some tips
on how I could solve it and then
this also gives us a bigger picture
of how we can face
each one  of these sites it is worth then,
in general, on the page of there
is how we can see what
if we could not see the main
problem would be that with the
alternative texts of the images
we could not identify what they
want to transmit to us each of
the
same images of  alternative contexts that they
give but that would be one of the
ways how we could solve
this page something very interesting is
that not all the tools are
perfect and well here comes something very
cool from the state that they know and
say okay when something confuses us  and we
can put it here in this section where it
says knicks rubio here he is marking us
5 where he tells us ok these sites that I am going to
mark you here I don't know if they are really
some sites it's up to you to evaluate it
so yes yes yes they remind you at that time
we pass here the color cons and it happened
then it means that it is a false
positive that is to say that it is marked as a
niche but we already verified it and it is not so
then we do not pay attention to it and
our backlog is a little
cleaner from these sites the same if we
Let's go to the next one, here it tells us ok I do
n't understand the contrasts here, it's
up to you to analyze them manually
and well, this is how you can
solve them no yes yes no no it does not present
any issue in the contrast and we pass
our scope of  accessibility, well,
nothing happens, okay, I don't know if there are any doubts up to
here
[Music],
although I think we won't
move on to the example, let's run sachs depp
tools
in the part here, well, this is almost the
shovel option, but the free one is here,
so we'll start it  to work
and it says son we found 37 starts and well
here are all the
features no and now let's see what
implications this has when we
start running one is that
actually in this case I'm going to press
control alt which is the shortcut to
run nvidia  What is this screen reader
for text? It has very
interesting tools such as what we see here, which
is the speechguard where we can
see what it is reading to us if, for
example, it has blindfolded in case
we had hearing problems and
could not hear what envy tells us.
Well, we can read it in this
part here. Let's remember that there are two
ways to navigate, it behaves and with pure
up and down arrows
with tact, look, we began to go through
all the interactive elements, including
Nvidia, and I enabled this option so
that it would hi like in  where we are
positioned I click this I go to the second
button I click this I go to another button and
so on between each of the
interactive elements Gavira this is very
strange because when we start with
accessibility we say ok what
is happening I want to read that title and
not  You are reading it to me because it is because
here we have to make use of the
second type of navigation that is
with up and down arrows. Now what
I am going to do is press the
down arrow and you will see how
now I am going to jump  towards towards the text
so in this case it is reading me
that it is a head and of level 4 and it is
announcing to me what that
element says I have a problem with my
machine I don't know why I can't give
sum to this text here  A thousand apologies
if you can't see it well, but
that's not being
read, the type of element is
telling us the level of the element, the text
that that element has so that we
can understand it, then we see a
heading level 4 and  well, what it
is saying or the text that this
element has then something very interesting
is also that for example in this case it
is marking me with a pink red color
or something like that because it is not an
interactive element what happens if I move now
a  interactive element like the button
that says that you are start for fresh and there I made a mistake
this one so we click it
below and now I mark it in blue
because all the interactive elements are blue
now let's go back the same to the elements
that are not interactive and it is not being
tapping on the previous interactive element through
which we go through this
helps us to identify how we have been
browsing previously another
curious fact about envy is that, for
example, there are also words that
we do not understand and we would like to
know how they are described so
perhaps we are seeing in this  title in
the first letter an extra square that
is yellow in color that is
positioned at the same time this tells us
that we can also navigate in
each of the letters of the words
in which we are navigating as
we navigate between each one of them here
if  we use the left
or right arrows and see how this
yellow rectangle begins to move
between each of the letters I am going to
press the right arrow and it will go to
uv it will go to y to l
to space  and thus between each of the
elements, then this is of the utmost
importance when we want to know how
a word is written, a text in the
title, whatever happens when
we reach the end, since they are in
ascending order, it will move us to the
next element and  Now we are in
the next element, so this is
like the most important thing when
navigating with what screen riders are
because we may be navigating badly and
detecting vices that maybe they are not,
if not problems that we do not understand
how they work.  these assistive technologies
now and what are we going to do with all this
well let's start browsing
ok I'm browsing on this
button it can't go through the image right now
it's telling me there is a
head and level 5 stats that's another little
problem  What is
this this envy that if we scroll
and the focus stays on an element it marks
something like this that it moved at some
point and we don't understand where it is
but for example well in this case because
I'm already in the state not pass  Because of the
image I already lost information there with
the image I also lost the icon right now
but you are reading me in this text
I am coming to this other more text more
text and right now at this moment I am in
the title but the saying that I tell you about
the  displacement that is to say I read it I
also read it in this case I am
going through this same element but by the
time we start well
look I'll explain it again I don't know if you
can see it but I'm already in
this text where it says where the title  it is
grow together in this case we see the
yellow square that is in the g but
if we go down it is not
changing the elements, they are just
moving the yellow rectangle in the
same text and this is an
envy configuration and because I have it
configured to read me a maximum of
100 characters and so I can
understand the text more, for example
if it is very important or very
overwhelming information for me, this gives me time to
process what I am hearing and I
can move among others  elements
then now yes yes I click the down arrow
and I go to the next element at
this moment I am in this typical the
title that says flowing conversation I go
down I am in the text also
the 100 characters and so it went through
each of the  elements but I am not
going through each one of the images
so if this image had
important information then I
would already be missing what
the author of the page wants to tell me with
these images
well the buttons and more text in
this case the phone  the email
here is something very interesting that I
told you with the links we are
seeing what facebook says but at the same
time it is telling us that
a page opens
from here as it is a list it
is also indicating it to me that
it says ok  These are a list with three
elements and of which the first is
this is a link so if I had my
eyes closed I would say ok I got to
a list there are three elements there are three
options of the first the first is
facebook I don't want to open it I give
down arrow and so I can scroll through the
other elements so when I'm
in the third one I say ok and so the third
element then when I
click the down arrow I'm going to leave that
list of elements and even the write
reader doesn't  it says here in this part
quote from here it tells us you are already out of
the list the element you are
reading right now is a head in level 3 and
the title is news read then well
in this way I can navigate between these
elements now let's see the
special options  What do the
raiders write? In this case, I'm going to press the
insert efe 7 key and I got a
special menu where I list all the
elements that this page has, all
the links, all the headings, all the
forms, buttons and the landmarks. The
landmarks are these  specific
semantic tags necessary to identify
each of the parts of our html
for example a head in on mein führer an
app among others as this page is not
accessible it cannot find them so
therefore not
nvidia and was not able to detect each
one  of the sections and it says man I'm
sorry I
only have this to offer you and it is
what it shows us now here comes the
importance of the headings where as you
can see we structure the information
depending on the genes that we
begin to declare if there is one
inside another  he puts it as a his pin as a
subtitle or if there are more within that
well he also puts them
consecutively so that's why it's
important I don't know if there are more questions
in the chat up to now
and he
thinks it's not
perfect then  these special menus
allow us to navigate between the entire
page and well nvidia and it's super big it
has shortcuts it has a way of navigating
software only between the g eddings
between the lists without opening this option
but I think she would have to
expand a little more be ok  We already saw
that we don't have the marx we don't have a
good semantic html the same if we go to
the code we can detect this everything
is a dip they
are all buttons this is not very
strange no so that's why in video and it
couldn't be able to detect this  part
then let's see how many sites
only using semantic html and
all the benefits that we can give
to the users fixes us so we have 37
we come to the code I leave this when I
close it because suddenly actor that
when I'm not used to
start talking to you
as we can see well we have the head
that this is part of the next and it is this
is a super simple application in
exile it is nothing complicated and this and well
as we can see it has there is a dip there is an
app in there is a header there is another day here it
has  a comment to know where
the email goes and well there is no führer either
so we have to add these 313
tags that would be header that would be the
main and that would be the führer and let's see
how many sites we can solve so
we delete this we put there but
we can't führer we go
to  the main
where it is
here it is
and in the part here we can announce
everyone
let me know that I'm wrong that
the xerez is so we only put 3
this one
here pass kirin
three tags only and we use
semantic html we go to the page and see
what happened to simple  vista nothing has happened
it is refreshing automatically
novovisión in the compilation and we are going to
refresh to see what happens what
happened ladies and gentlemen from 37
we went to 10 so with this we can
see the power the responsibility and everything
that entails  have a
semantic html so if we open
the nvidia again
but this here it is and if we
open the menu option again and go
to the landmark now if it tells us ah ok
look you know that it can already detect a
banner it can already detect a mail  and it
can now detect the content, the content
calls the forum that way, so if
we click on automatic we
can move to that section and it is
easier for the user to start
using each of these options
then the truth was when I started
learning about accessibility this blew my
mind because with great power
comes great responsibility and the
truth is that they are little things that do not cost us
anything
to do, for example it did not cost us anything
from the beginning they defined maine
define the führer the header and in this
way we can  help many
people to be able to solve
this I am going to close again envy
oh haiti
and this the same now let's see for example
this beginning of the color contrast not
that at first glance it looks cool but it is not
accessible enough for
all people to use it  you can see
first we are going to see how
people with different
visual disabilities would see it in the part here we
go to more tools and there is an option
called rendering where we
click masters and go down we will find
this option that says emulate vision emulate
visual deficiencies so if
we click on it we can simulate
blurred vision for example that a
person would see it like this the problem but
so ignore sorry then suddenly I
got stuck where for example you can't see the
combinations with red this would be seen by
blue people this other  disease
that also sees it a little more in
grayscale
now that it can't see the combinations, it
seems to me that with blue and achromatopsia,
which is flat when they can't see
the color combinations that
see everything more or less black and white then
In this way we can emulate the
different types of
visual disabilities and how
our platform would look with each one of
them. This is very important because
we are used to the fact that, for example,
there is a form, there is a problem and under
that entry we put the issue.
red, but for example, I
cannot see the colors or the
combinations with red, I would see it blue and
that is a risk because we
are not transmitting the information
correctly to the user, what
we could do is accompany it with a
warning icon  or error is the eibor
and then maybe we can't
identify the colors but if the
icons and that could be a
solution to that type of them
ok so here we have the
simulations and now let's see our
colors because they are not passing the le
I'm going to give a little more stop here
so that they can take out that color and I'm going to
take it with this which is the pink color
and the background color
so as you can see well this is the
background color this is the color of my
button  and he is telling me you know that
you are not passing at any level of
accessibility, you do not have the minimum to
be able to pass it and so we are
running with the video team with the
weiss team and tell them they know that
friends this part is not being
accessible you have to  change the colors and
then they tell you oh ok no problem
and we had already planned it so
now we are going to change the colors and we
are going to use this as a
cooking recipe because I already brought it prepared this one
that I made
in
and well with that it would be solved
more
then we already made the changes and we
put them in the code they have already changed we close
this part of the rendering and we go back to
analyze our page and well since we
have everything in variables as
we use a good practice of this code we
can modify it and it was super
incredible so this  Well, now
we don't have four issues left that has
to do with the images that we see, which
is this one that does not have the
alternative text, which other does not have the
alternative text, this other one does not have to be
corrected, and here we have a
problem with the Hennings that  They say
that it has to grow one by one
because if we inspect it to begin with,
it's where and well, you don't
understand it so I don't understand it either.
where I
would like to give you the most
important message d
of semantic html and it is if the tag exists
use without yes only in very
extreme cases you have to modify the
behavior do it why with the
roll attribute we can
rebuild redefine the
native behavior of this tag  For example,
studying this, it is no longer a type that
is behaving like a
level 4 head in, so roughly speaking it would be
an h4 so it is not
highly recommended to do this if there is an h 4 you have
to use it and only in very
extreme cases  make use of this part there is
something very interesting I also know that it
is already a lot of information but I still
promise you that it would be the last thing is this
part that we see here that says
accessibility where it really shows us
the accessibility tree that it
uses in assistive technologies  So
that they can transmit the
information that appears on the screen to the user,
many times I have had to see what they say,
no, you know that I already tried
the accounting navigation order on my page, it is
incredible, it is going to go to accessibility
and then it turns out that I activate envy and
I start to analyze the page and I tell it
man, that is, this is not being accessible
because you did not test it with an
assistive technology when we activate an
assistive technology, the first thing it starts doing is the
combination between the dom between some
parts of 7 and in the
accessibility tree then  how do you do this
match and now a new character comes into play
that is this tree so if
we only do it without enabling
assistive technology this new tree is not coming into
action without instead
this tree tells us ah ok well look
now you will have  It indicates the role, the
properties, the attributes, even the
states that our components are going to have. That
is why it is super important
to review it here because it can also
give us an idea of ​​how the real screen will read it,
for example, the examples,
since below  the links of the social networks
we can see that it tells us ok it
will not read it as a link that says
facebook and then it says open and new is and
we say here the idea did not come out
that special text because we inspect
the element we expand it and we can  see
that there is this hidden spam this hidden spam
and it just has a class that
says screen reader only for example that
is only then these are
accessibility tricks where we get a little
crafty and say ok
the screen ryder also has to say
the same  what does this say and with a milestone
then what we must do is this
transmit that same information to the
user but how can we do it
well we make a crop
of this element as loapa as it appears
here in 7 is where what
we are simply doing is putting it  of a pixel
by a pixel where with the naked eye, well,
people who do not
use assistive technologies cannot see it, but
because we already have that landmark icon,
but people who cannot see it, well,
at least they can hear it and,
well, everything that  We can
transmit it to the user without disabilities, it
also has to be transmitted in the
same way to users who have
a disability in that way, since
we do not generate statements, okay,
well, I think that would be all.